bonsoir bienvenue ravi de vous retrouver
dans Ça vous regarde ce soir le jour où
Israël a basculé dans l'effroid bonsoir
Jérémy André merci d'être notre grand
témoin ce soir vous revenez de l'État
hébreux pour le point le point qui
publie cette semaine un travail
remarquable le grand récit sur 30 pages
sur ce crime atroce que vous racontez
heure par heure 1400 personnes assassiné
des femmes des enfants des vieillards
dans une opération terroriste et on le
comprend mieux en vous lisant préparé de
longues dates et ultra coordonné on va
en parler dans la deuxième partie tous
les deux notre grand débat ce soir le
made in France a-t-il toujours la côte
avec l'inflation les ménages surveillent
de près leurs dépenses alors comment les
marques françaises tentent de riposter
le Tricolore est-il trop cher les aides
aux entreprise suffisante le salon du
made in France est ouvert Porte de
Versailles on en parle dans un instant
sur ce plateau avec mes invités enfin
nous affranchi ce soir le mot de la
semaine de Mariette darrygrand action
planète la chronique écolo de Léa Falco
et puis Bourbon Express signé Stéphanie
des pierres voilà pour le menu on y va
Jérémy André ça vous regarde et bien ça
commence
[Musique]
maintenant près de 1000 exposants aux
couleurs du drapeau français c'est donc
ce salon Made in France qui s'est ouvert
Porte de Versailles à Paris dans un
contexte plutôt morose l'inflation
freine vraiment la consommation de
produits français alors faut-il s'en
inquiéter à l'heure de la reconquête
industrielle comment garantir des
débouchés au produits relocalisé bonsoir
Ellie Cohen bonsoir bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes économiste directeur
de recherche auocnrs c'est votre dernier
ouvrage et parfaitement dans notre thème
de débat souveraineté industrielle vers
un nouveau modèle productif c'était chez
ODIL Jacob en 2022 bonsoir Béatrice
Mathieu ravi de vous retrouver sur ce
plateau vous êtes grand reporte à
L'Express chargé des pages chcho bonsoir
Yve g bienvenue ancien ministre et
fondateur de la certification Origine
France Garantie on en dira un mot enfin
bonsoir Olivier remoissonnet et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes le
directeur général de la brosserie
française on va en voir quelques
exemples on va dire très concrètement
sur sur le plateau vous fabriquez des
brosses 100 % française et
écooresponsable mais aussi je crois des
brosses à cheveux vous nous direz
comment vous êtes adapté à ce contexte
de hausse des prix vous êtes journaliste
Jérémy André c'est pas vos sujet mais
n'hésitez pas pour plus de pédagogie à
interroger nos invités quand vous le
souhaitez on commence par planter le
décor état de santé du made in France
c'est dans le chrono de Blacko qu'on
accueille tout de
suite bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir
Miriam bonsoir à toutes et tous alors
comment il va le produire français ah
ben on en parle ce soir du Madine France
parce que ce weekend à Paris se tient
regardez le 11e Salon la 11e édition
pardon du salon du made in France ça
veut dire que voilà donc déjà plus de 10
ans qu'on se soucie du made in France
dans notre pays si si il faut se
souvenir he c'était en en 2012 François
Hollande venait d'être élu et il avait
nommé on le voit on le voit le salon ça
l'édition voilà mais puisque c'était il
y a maintenant plus de 10 ans la
première édition je vous rappelle qu'
François Hollande avait nommé Arnaud
mondbourg ministre du redressement
productif et que le sémiant ministre et
justement répétait sur tous les tons que
il était urgent de à nouveau produire
mon France on
l'écoute consommateurs doivent mettre du
ma in France dans leur chariot c'est la
marinière d'Armor luxe le robot Seb
fabriqué à surti et cetera et cetera
tout le monde doit s'y mettre pour faire
renaître l'industrie française quel Foug
quel entraint pour promouvoir la
réindustrialisation de notre pays alors
bien sûr cétait il y a 10 ans donc on se
demande où on est-on aujourd'hui alors
la bonne nouvelle c'est que les pouvoirs
publics sont toujours soucieux de
réindustrialiser regardez ça c'était le
candidat Macron c'était sa promesse de
campagne en 2017 un plan Marshal pour la
réindustrialisation et bien 6 ans plus
tard après avoir réété élu son prochain
défi à Emmanuel Macron ça sera croi la
réindustrialisation il y a une vraie
constance dans la démarche bon je fais
un peu de mauvais esprit parce qu'en
réalité la poli que du président Macron
a quand même donné quelques résultats
notamment quand on regarde le sold entre
ouverture et fermeture d'usine vous
voyez qu'à partir de 2017 le sold est
devenu positif sauf pendant le covid
alors que c'était pas le cas auparavant
cela dit 106 usines crées de plus que
celles qui ont fermé c'est pas énorme
alors bien sûr va on compte sur iicen
pour nous expliquer pourquoi c'est si
difficile de relocaliser mais en même
temps quand on demande aux Français pour
eux la réponse elle est très simple hein
vous allez voir oui bien sûr on voudrait
acheter français 90 % des des gens le
sont prêts à le faire mais pourtant on
restreint nos achats en France et la
raison vous la connaissez en tout cas la
première des raisons c'est que 70 % des
Français pensent que les produits
français sont trop chers donc c'est
certainement lié au coût de la main
d'œuvre en France je peux vous donner un
exemple par exemple Bruno leemer avait
mis une grosse pression sur Peugeot pour
qu'ils assemblent leur nouvelle 208
électrique en France ça c'était début
juillet donc début octobre voilà Peugeot
annonce que la Peugeot électrique sera
construite en Espagne et c'est dommage B
c'est dommage cela dit en Espagne le
SMIC est à 1000 € et il est à 1500 € en
France ce qui peut évidemment expliquer
ce choix alors que faire je sais pas
mais peut-être que par exemple les
pouvoirs publics pourrai donner
l'exemple voyez au moment d'acheter du
matériel pour l'administration acheter
du matériel français dans des usines
françaises oui mais alors il y a un
problème c'est qu'on appartient à
l'Union européenne et que au sein de
l'Union européenne le libre échange est
la seule voie possible donc pas question
de offrir des priorités national pour au
moment de faire des offres de marché
public pourtant ce qui fabrique en
France il réclame ça on a un fabriquant
France à ici il y en a un autre qui est
celui du slip français qui fabrique des
vêtements en le slip oui c'éit une
marque amusante mais il fabrique du
textile en France ce qui est vraiment un
défi par qu'il y a seulement 3 % des
produits textiles qui sont fabriqués en
France donc lui il aimerait être soutenu
justement par des marchés publics où il
serait privilégiés en Europe ou en
France on l'écoute la réalité c'est que
dans notre métier le textile l'immense
majorité des marchés publics en fait son
remporté par des boîtes chinoises ou des
fabrications en tout cas chinoises ou
bangladises et en fait en ne voulons pas
nous faire de concurrence en nous on
laisse rentrer sur le marché toutes ces
importations qui viennent de loin et on
aurait tous intéress que ce soit
fabriqué beaucoup plus localement ah oui
donc relocalisé donc tout le monde est
d'accord en revanche dès qu'on prononce
le mot protectionnisme alors là on a dit
un gros mot d'ailleurs je me demande
comment j'ai osé dire ça mais en tout
cas il y a un débat parce que ça peut
être une solution merci beaucoup merci
Stéphane blakovski allez Olivier
remoissonis je commence avec vous déjà
cette baisse des des ventes qu'on a
constaté est-ce que vous vous l'avez
constaté à à votre entreprise donc la
brosserie est-ce que est-ce que vous
avez dû vous adapter peut-être même
baisser les prix alors cette baisse elle
est elle est pas représentative de tous
les marchés on voit bien que il y a un
fléchage de la consommation sur les
produits à plus bas prix c'est un vrai
débat d'ailleurs de savoir s'il est
utile d'aller flécher cette consommation
sur les produits made in aur puisqu'on
sait que majoritairement le les produits
à bas prix sont des produits
d'importation donc on ait tout le débat
sur qui se cache derrière et qui
contribue à quoi quand on fait du
medineur il en reste pas moins que nous
on a démarré il y a 10 ans avec plutôt
les réseaux spécialisés qui sont des
réseaux qui souffre aujourd'hui et qu'il
faut soutenir parce que ce sont
aujourd'hui les plus vertueux mais
malgré tout chaque Français a le droit
d'avoir le choix dans son outil de dans
ses brosses à dents qu'il vont consommer
et donc être présent aussi en grande
distribution c'était pour nous un vrai
enjeu et depuis 3 ans on a positionné la
brosserie française sur ces produitl
c'est ça vous vous n'avez pas moins
vendu du tout franchement on a moins
vendu sur le réseau bio sur le réseau
bio mais on a accompagner les
consommateurs qui sont revenus plus
majoritairement sur le réseau de grande
distribution pour être présent et leur
offrir le choix d'un produit français y
compris dans la grande distribution
c'est ça pour vous le made in France ne
doit surtout pas être réservé à une
élite ça doit être ni élitiste ni
réservé à certains réseaux chaque
Français doit pouvoir avoir le choix
dans son rayon de consommer français
c'est le plus important du coup la
brosse à dents ou le lot de 3 en grande
surface c'est combien on est à moins de
5 € le lot 3 en grande surface on est
entre 3 € et 4 € en magasin bio sur sur
le produit unitaire avec des
philosophies complètes sur les les
boucles de recyclage parce que la Bros à
dent est un des produits qui pollue le
plus parce que c'est un amalgame de
différents composants donc derrière
l'outil se C se cache aussi son impact
environnemental et en minaur on se
préoccupe pas de ça et vous faites vos
marges où alors sur les production vous
serrez la vis où pour arriver à des cou
c'est touours la question qu'on me pose
parce que finalement on n'est pas plus
cher que les marques international et
pour autant on est en prix de revien
beaucoup plus cher c'est simplement
qu'on a un outil de commun iation un
outil de rémunération de l'actionnariat
qui n'a rien à voir avec ce que font les
les majur qui sont sur notre réseau
c'est-à-dire les grandes marques
multinationales nous on a une politique
de rémunération qui est au juste prix et
des différents maillons de distribution
donc bien sûr on rémunère nos réseaux de
distribution mais on rémunère aussi
notre activité et nos salariés de
manière plus équitable que des produits
d'importation sur lesquels on va faire
des
plusvalues en terme de coût marketing et
de coût de rémunération donc ça marche
même dans une période difficile qui peut
être que conjoncturelle Béatrice Mathieu
exemple des brosses à dents là n'est
absolument pas représentatif de ce qui
se passe sur le marché des produits made
in France d'abord parce que tout le
monde peut pas s'offrir particulièrement
dans le textile j'ai vu que c'était un
des secteurs les plus impactés un jean à
100 € un t-shirt à 40 € alors
expliquez-nous ce qui se passe plus
personne n'achète français dans certains
secteurs lesquels non alors c'est il y a
pas il y a pas un refus du M France pas
du tout il y a d'ailleurs vous l'avez
tout à fait dit dans dans les sondages
en fait année après année il y a la
volonté des Français d'acheter d'acheter
madeine France parce que c'est un gage
ils y voient un gage de qualité
d'éthique des corresponsabilités de
voilà il nempêche que les ventes
baissent il n'empêche que les ventes
baissent comme comme dans le bio hein
d'ailleurs et souvent quand vous avez du
made in France bio là c'est la double la
double peine parce que le marché du bio
c'est littéralement effondré alors ce
qui se passe sur le marché du du textile
et de l'habillement est un peu
particulier parce que tout le secteur du
textile et de l'habillement a énormément
souffert même quand c'est pas du made in
France et vous avez une sorte de
schizophrénie aussi du consommateur qui
veut effectivement euh acheter euh made
in France qui le dit dans les enquêtes
et puis m même aussi souvent les jeunes
hein don qui disent ah ben nous on
promeut ces marques là et qui euh qui
traduit pas ça dans les actes et qui
traduisent pas ça complètement dans les
actes et on voit bien euh le succès
incroyable de Shine par exemple pour ne
pas les citer c'est la fast fashion
chinoise F F fast fashion ou même si on
on replonge de G 2 ans auparavant quand
on est sorti de 3 ans et quand on est
sorti du confinement on avait les les
fils les les fils de de les les que de
de gens qui attendaient d'aller chezent
n'ont pas résisté d'ailleurs à à cette
crise est-ce qu'il y a eu des fermetures
d'activités de d'entreprise 100 %
trcolor ah ben quelques quelquesunes
hein forcément mais c'est c'est un
espèce de de de comment dire de de vid
des affaires aussi qui est assez
inéluctable donc tout ne se tout ne
souffre pas il y a des modèles qui
marchent et puis
c'est en fait les modèles qui marchent
sont très réfléchis dans la construction
de leur modèle économique en fait dans
la dans la maîtrise de leur coût dans
aussi beaucoup d'innovation en fait pour
pour faire baisser en fait les coûts de
production et c'est c'est pour ça que la
la construction en fait du du business
model est très très importante pour pour
expliquer ça et le signal prix reste
quand même imp importantvg quoi qu'on en
dise qu'est-ce que c'est exactement le
made in France c'est pas forcément des
entreprises françaises ah non il faut je
pense qu'il y a une grande confusion il
y a la confusion entre la marque et
l'origine aujourd'hui vous achetez une
Renault Clio vous dites j'achète une
voiture française pas de chance elle est
faite en Turquie vous achetez une
Renault Yar une Toyota Yaris vous dit
bah là j'achète une voiture japonaise
pas de chance elle est faite à
Valencienne donc il faut d'abord
distinguer la marque et l'origine faut
distinguer si je dire la nationalité de
l'entreprise d'ailleurs ça ne veut plus
rien dire mais ma France a mis son siège
social au Pays-Bas donc Toyota prod en
France c'est du made in France les
voitures qui sortent de l'usine de
Toyota sont made in France elles sont
même Origine France Garantie puisque la
certification que nous avons créée avec
un certain nombre de chefs d'entreprise
depuis maintenant 12 ans à peu près la
même époque que l'arrivée de d'Arnaud
Montebourg aux affaires c'est une
certification qui vient vérifier si le
produit que vous achetez est bien
français vous avez vu il y a 35 % des
gens qui dans le sondage disent euh je
voudrais bien être sûr que ce que
j'assète chis français alors on peut le
dire tout de suite si vous voyez du bleu
blanc rouge ou si vous voyez une marque
française c'est pas forcément un produit
français et la seule chose qui compte
c'est dans quelle usine le produit
a-t-il été fabriqué peu importe la
nationalité des actionnaires ou la
marque ouais vous l'avez vu cette
transformation de culture de
consommation est-ce que c'est profond et
donc la crise est conjoncturelle on va
revenir à une consommation tricolore ou
au fond c'est pas si clair que ça c'est
profonde on a vu changer dans les esp pr
cette idée que la préoccupation de
l'origine est devenue la deuxième
préoccupation des acheteurs la première
c'est est-ce que je peux me
l'offrir c'est basique et vient tout de
suite après l'item d'où ça vient sur ce
sujet donc ça c'est une réalité et comme
vous le disiez depuis une dizaine
d'années on a vu évoluer cette demande
de de connaissance de l'origine et en
nombre d'emplois c'est combien d'emplois
en France le made in France on sa ben
déjà depuis 50 ans c'est un million
d'emplois en moins puisque depuis 50 ans
on a passé de 20 % en gros de la part de
l'industrie dans le PIB à 10 % donc on a
perdu énormément d'emplo sur ce sujet
aujourd combien de salariés
d'entreprises qui
travaillentorscom don parce que j'ai
cherché aujourd'hui et j'ai pas trouvé
je vois des choses très
très les miens sur ce sujet mais mais
pour pour terminer sur sur cette
question je pense que c'est c'est
beaucoup plus essentiel qu'on le pense
on prend ça et et merci de nous inviter
aujourd'hui mais c'estons du madeine
France ça peut un peu sourire c'est un
peu anecdote je pense que un produit un
pays qui ne produit plus est un pays qui
meurt et que produire en France c'est un
projet de société c'est pas le chapitre
de d'un programme politique d'un
gouvernant c'est un projet de société et
qu'une société doit s'organiser autour
de la production la production la plus
modeste de celui qui fait des salades
dans son jardin la production la plus
élaborée sur ce sujet non je veux dire
ça parce que la France sans usine c'est
fini c'est même si c'est B mis du temps
le patronat a plaidé une partie du
patronat plaider pour les
délocalisations pendant de longues
années et on a oublié la noblesse du
geste de produire qui est pas une
noblesse de surannée c'est le moteur de
la société une société qui ne produit
plus et qui n'a plus d'usine est une
société condamnée IC Cohen moi je
voulais avoir votre regard sur une
actualité économique de de ces derniers
jours on va parler des moyens de
relocaliser des politiques économiques
de soutien aux industries mais la fin du
masque sanitaire français ça c'est quand
même quelque chose on est 3 ans après le
début de la pandémie on a découvert
notre dépendance au chinois et puis ça
marche pas et donc finalement à
efficacité égal mais beaucoup trop cher
en france on arrête qu'est-ce que ça dit
ça de de de cette question du madeine
France ça résume bien la trajectoire de
la question industrielle c'est-à-dire
qu'il a 3 ans quand il y a eu la crise
du covid on a découvert avec effroid que
l'accès à des biens qu'on considérait
comme aussi important était devenu
impossible parce qu'on avait fait le
Paris que grâce au libre échange grâce à
la division internationale du travail
grâce à la mondialisation on aurait
toujours accès au bien dont on a besoin
et puis on a découvert soudain la
pénurie la dépendance et là comme
d'habitude dans ces cas-là sur saut on
fait appel à l'état et on convoque deux
ou trois entreprises et on leur demande
de fabriquer des masques assez
rapidement on leur demande même de les
fabriquer en tissu parce que à l'époque
on était pas capable mais 3 ans après le
marché 3 ans après ben le marché a
repris le dessus et il n'y a pas de vol
volé sur la durée d'installer la
consommation de biens produits sur le
territoire national est-ce que je peux
vous interrompre je pense aussi qu'il y
a pas d'achat massif et la question de
l'achat public il est majeur depuis 1930
les États-Unis d'Amérique achètent 50 %
de ce qu'ils achètent en achat public
aux entreprises américaines point à la
ligne c'est comme ça c'est pas autrement
moi je pense que tant qu'on a'ura pas
pris une m une partie de la manne de
l'achat public en France c'est 120
milliards par an hein juste pour la
France si on prenait 25 % de l'achat
public avec de l'achat obligatoire pour
des produits français et bien les
hôpitaux et bien les grands acheteurs
publics pourraient donner ces marchés à
des usines qui pourrai investir dans des
machines et faire baisser les PR non
justement ça a été dit ça a été dit tout
à l'heure le le grand dessin européen
depuis 30 ans c'est le marché unique et
on a tout fait pour réaliser un grand
marché unique européen et marché unique
et ben ça veut dire à la fois
l'abaissement des frontières internes ça
veut dire le fait que justement la
commande publique c'est une commande
publique qui se fait au niveau européen
et non pas au niveau national donc il
n'est pas possible de privilégier auour
hein mais on peut changer les choses ah
non mais on peut on peut sortir de
l'Europe aussi oui si c'est ça
votre carz pas on peut faire évolidé
essentielle c'est le marché unique je
continue mon raisonnement on pourrait
dire bah à tout le moins les Européens
devraient faire comme les américains
c'est-à-dire réserver à des producteurs
européens la la production
de bien dont on a besoin au niveau
européen aux États-Unis il y a un by
American Act qui permet justement à la
puissance publique de faire cette
commande publique réservée au
producteurs sur le sol américain on
pourrait faire un by European Act mais
on peut pas faire quelques promesses
présidentielles de de précédent candidat
c'était François Le protectioniste s'il
est pas national il peut être européen
alors justement on va y venir à cette
question parce que les choses elles
changent elles évoluent mais on va quand
même se rendre porte de versaill et je
vous donne la parole juste après quelles
sont les motivations
pour acheter français et comment les
chefs d'entreprise très concrètement
font face à cette crise du made in
France regardez cet reportage de Dario
borgogot avec Ivana navion qui a
rencontré un patron qui produit des
jeans 100 % français
reportage des chaussures au cahier ici
tout est fabriqué en France les stands
du salon présentent uniquement des
produits garantis origine France la
problématique c'est que maintenant le
consommateur il croit que sur certaines
filières il existe plus de produits
français et c'est une formidable vitrine
ce salon pour montrer que tous les
secteurs d'activité peuvent être
représentés et que si on le veut on peut
consommer des produits made in France
les gens ont envie de traçabilité envie
de il y a une vraie qute de sens quand
vous achetez un produit français vous
achetez un produit avec derrière des
emplois avec derrière des impôts enfin
ça donne ça donne bonne conscience
d'acheter un produit madeine France et
en plus il est beau il est de qualité il
Durre et parmi les succès du salon cette
marque de je présente depuis la première
édition mission réussie pour une filière
disparue en France la filière du je
était complètement délocalisé en 2013
quand on a relancé la marque mais rest
des tisseurs en France donc on allit
avoir des tisseurs pour reser du denim
en France il rest des confectionneur il
av plus de Jean mais on allit les voir
pour refaire du jean en France et petit
à petit en créant nos propres ateliers à
leur côté et bien on a fait grandir la
filière et donc on est passé de de mon
petit frère et moi à 250 dans la filière
aujourd'hui cette année la marque
localiser un de ses ateliers au sein du
salon une manière de justifier des prix
parfois élevés et dans l'espace boutique
les clients acceptent de tel tarif si
c'est pour avoir de meilleurs jeans j'ai
plus envie en fait d'acheter des des
produits qui voyagent trop voilà qui
produent la planète indirectement
également qui exploite aussi peut-être
des gens à l'autre bout du monde donc
j'ai plus envie d'acheter moins
d'articles mais avec voilà quelque chose
qui a plus de sens pour moi bon bien sûr
il faut des prix pour tout le monde mais
plus de production en France plus on
pourra aussi avoir des très attractif en
gardant une bonne qualité 1083 propose
des jeans autour de 130 €. ses
concurrents fabriquant à l'étranger
coûte bien moins cher avec une
différence parfois de plus de 50 €. et
voilà la question du du prix encore et
toujours et les Cohen euh il faut
travailler quoi pour avoir des chances
sur les marchés du made in France
l'avantage comparatif euh des des
secteur de l'économie d d'avenir ou sur
des jeans comme ça si c'est de la
qualité il y a des perspectives bah il
faut bien sûr combiner plusieurs types
d'actions le choix qui a été fait par le
gouvernement me semble être un choix
judicieux c'est-à-dire il est illusoire
de penser que on va relocaliser en
France qui a été délocalisé hier terme à
terme ça ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens par
contre par exemple dans le domaine de
l'industrie automobile il faut profiter
du passage à la mobilité électrique qui
nécessite d'autres types de moteurs
d'autres types de batteries d'autres
types de d'assemblage ça commence nord
de laance VO pour localiser sur le
territoire d'où la politique du
gouvernement qui consiste à dire pour le
passage au nouvelles génération on va
produire en France en faisant en sorte
que les entreprises qui veulent se
localiser sur le territoire national il
soient incité financièrement par la mise
à disposition de gens formés par la mise
à disposition de terrain en créant des
écosystèmes industriels pour qu'il
puisse y avoir des échanges pour qu'il
puisse y avoir une sous-traitance
insérée dans le système prod uctif alors
on fait ça dans le domaine de la
mobilité électrique mais on peut le
décliner dans des domain
dansucteur ça c'est des secteurs
d'avenir on appelle ça les technologies
de de rupture c'est pas votre crédau je
pense que c'est c'est un c'est un volet
à ne pas oublier et qui est important de
soutenir parce que ce sont aussi les
emplois de demain mais il faut aussi se
dire que la consommation en France
repose sur les biens de consommation
courant et que les biens de consommation
courant sont les premiers vecteurs de
création de richesse et d'emploi à court
terme et donc ne pas saisir cette
opportunité de continuer à produire en
France des brosses adans mais aussi des
jein et vous attendez quand même de
l'aide du soutien de l'état financier
d'accompagnement vous dites on peut y
arver tout se pe l'espérer on peut le
solliciter on peut le demander la vérité
c'est que il faut qu'on se donne les
moyens aussi en tant que entreprise
d'accompagner le mouvement il y a une
chose qui est certaine c'est que les
consommateurs même s'ils en ont pas tous
les moyens ont tous l'envie de changer
leur mode de consommation tion on a tous
conscience que la planète ne peut plus
vivre ce qu'elle a vécu sur les 40 ou 50
dernières années et qu'il appartient au
marc de proposer des solutions
alternatives attendre des
accompagnements c'est important d'être
soutenu c'est important mais il faut que
les initiatives viennent aussi des
marques moi j'entendre mon entreprise
qu'elle accompagne ce changement et
qu'elle soit présente dans les tous les
réseaux pour que les consommateurs on
les éduque aussi dans ce changement et
qu'on les accompagne dans cette
pédagogie du changement peut-être qu'il
faudra aussi réfléchir au salaire pour
pouvoir aussi changer les les façons de
de consommer Béatrice Mathieu il se
passe quelque chose en France quand même
le coût du travail a baissé la France
est plus attractive mais on part de très
très loin est-ce qu'on a on redevient
suffisamment attractif par rapport à nos
voisins et par rapport à l'Allemagne à
qui on se compare toujours bah il y a la
question du coût du travail il y a la
question des impôts de production donc
sur les impôts de production bah on a il
y a des des des efforts qui ont été
faits même si aujourd'hui les écarts en
fait de coût de production entre d'impôt
de production entre la la France et
l'Allemagne sont toujours à la au
désavantage de de la France sur le coût
du travail dans l'industrie
manufacturière les écarts entre la
France et l'Allemagne ne sont pas
considérables donc c'est pas tellement
là que que que que se joue joue la
différence ce sont des choix de
politique industrielle plus anciens dans
le je dire l'Allemagne depuis n'a pas
fait n'a pas vécu cette terrible
désindustrialisation et délocalisation
que que que l'on a que l'on a vécu ils
ont gardé ils ont gardé tout un
écosystème aussi d'industriel de
sous-traitant de sous-traitant de second
rang 3è rang et ce qui fait qu'ils ont
une base industrielle qui n'a qui n'a
rien à voir avec la nôtre et donc c'est
et donc c'est c'est moins compliqué en
fait que nous ou dans dans certains
secteurs le cas de monsieur qui disait
qu'il fallait tout reconstruire en fait
pour refaire des jeans parce qu'il y
avait tout simplement plus plus de de de
façonniers de toile et même plus de main
d'œuvre il y a des des des des secteurs
en fait où n même plus la main d'œuvre
pour travailler dans ces usines là
comment vous jugez la politique
industrielle d'Emmanuel Macron qu'il a
fait voilà sa grande priorité sur
l'ensemble he de de ces quin que que le
le Emmanuel Macron a freiné la chute qui
était une chute vertigineuse on voit
bien d'ailleurs dans les chiffres la
courbes qui tombent est devenu à plat
maintenant le défi c'est de remonter
c'est de ramener de l'industrie alors ça
passe effectivement par par ce qui é
évoqué tout au long de de ce débat c'est
vrai que les Allemands eux ont gardé une
tradition ils ont beaucoup plus
d'entreprises de taille intermédiaire
que nous ils ont une organisation
capitalistique notamment de capitalisme
familial ce qu'on pourrait appeler le
capitalisme Renant qui est beaucoup plus
solide qui est nous on s'est beaucoup
donné au fonds de pension aux
investisseurs aux actionnaires qui
cherchaient de la ratabilité absolue et
qui n'avaient pas cette culture du
maintien dans le territoire ça compte
aussi il y a le travail à faire sur la
productivité quand vous voyez le patron
et ça m'est arrivé il y a quelques
années de Toyota Europe je lui dis mais
pourquoi vous avez choisi valencienne
plutôt que un pays low cost en Europe
puisqu'il voulait produire en Europe
mais il me dit j'ai choisi valencienne
parce que l'État m'a accompagné c'était
avant l'actuel gouvernement ça veut dire
parce qu'on est plus productif mais
attention ça baisse et parce qu'on est
plus productif et qu'en gros il me dit
avec un salarié en France je fais ce que
je ferai avec deux salariés et demi dans
un pays de l'Est low cost sur ce sujet
il faut continuer à travailler ça faut
continuer à aider à à moderniser les
usines à faire des usines 2.0 3.0 on ira
jusque pour que le digital viennent
aider aussi à trouver cette rabilité
c'est c'est un grand défi
national et pardon de de de de marteler
ça mais c'est un projet de société au
fond moi je rêve du président de la
République qui va venir dire mon projet
c'est produire et on va organiser toute
la société autour de la production vous
vou réagir on a parlé des masques est-ce
que le problème aussi c'est pas une
forme de concurrence déloyale d'un
centre d'État donc dont la Chine par des
subventions par un dumping social
environnemental éthique et est-ce que on
a vraiment une marge de manœuvre ici à
oui bloquer certaines
importations dire c'est pas possible
mais l' devraitire au niveau européen on
a décidé justement de s'attaquer à ce
problème chinois on ne compte on ne dit
plus que on est dans une économie de
bisounours où l'idéal c'est la libre
circulation des biens sans contraintte
sans limite et cetera l'Europe a pris
des mesures 1 pour la limitation des
investissements chinois en Europe pour
éviter qu'il n'achète des entreprises
stratégiques de l'Europe a pris des
décisions pour s'attaquer aux subvention
aux entreprises chinoises et il y a une
commission qui a été mise en place pour
évaluer exactement les aides et pour
prendre des mesures de rétorsion 3
l'Europe a décidé de mettre en place des
mécanismes pour qu'il y ait une
réciprocité sur les marchés publics
c'est exactement donc on est sorti de la
naïveté le mot rorprocité c'est le mot
clé si vous nous imposions aux produits
chinois de respecter les mêmes normes
que nous imposons au produits français
européens on aurait gagné la partie sur
vous parliez de Chine tout à l'heure
pardon hein mais c'est de la merde et on
peut pas laisser cette mer de textile
être importée en France c'est c'est
c'est immonde de de laisser faire ça
c'est le mot réciproc vrai que voilà
c'est vrai que Y a en matière automobile
il faut regarder parce que il y a vous
voyez ce bonus électrique c'est
protectionnisme qui dit pas son nom et
qui en fait renchéri les voitures
produites à l'étranger en Chine qu'elle
soit française d'ailleurs ou qu'elle soi
chinoise par rapport aux voitures
produitite en France vous vous attendez
qu'on qu'on généralise ce ce genre de
dispositif non moi moi j'attends que
l'on réétablisse les assiettes de
contribution à notre modèle social et
économique parce que aujourd'hui je
prends l'exemple des brosses à dents moi
je fabrique 4 % des partarts du marché
français sur un produit de bien de
consommation on va dire pour une PME
c'est déjà pas mal sauf que je fabrique
4 % des parts de marché français et ça
veut dire 34 collaborateurs sont les
seuls à contribuer un modèle social à
travers les les charges sociales et les
charges patronales sont les seuls à
contribuer pour les 96 % des produits
qu'on apporte en France sur les brosses
à dents donc'appelle des barrièresèr ça
s'appelle la TVA sociale à partir du
moment où on veut bénéficier d'un
confort de vie d'hôpitaux et de services
publics il faut que les biens de
consommation ne soient pas uniquement
chargés sur ceux qui produisent en
France on les consomme en France il faut
qu'il y ait une équité sur la taxation
pour que les produits d' alors ça
s'appelle aussi la taxe carbone aux
frontières de l'Europe est-ce que ça ça
va dans le bon sens Béatrice Matthieu
est-ce qu'on doit voir au fond ces
règles de
concurrence changer et et sortir de la
naïveté être sur un véritable pied
d'égalité sur les questions éthiques sur
les questions environnemental alors sur
les alors il y a plein de choses sur la
taxe carbone si on prend d'ailleurs
c'est c'est le mot taxe carbone n'est
pas le bon puisque c'est contributions
c'est pas contribution carbone au
frontiè lesations
pas pas sur T les exportations c'est sur
un certain nombre très réduit de
secteurs c'est pas les brosses à dents
qui viennent de Chine ou je ne sais où
d'ailleurs elle il y a pas il y a pas
aujourd'hui dans les projets en fait de
la Commission européenne de mettre une
contribution carbone sur les c'est sur
certains sur par sur une BR ou parce que
c'est très comp TR qure fois moins
émetteur carb une BR c'est extrêmement
compliqué en fait de voir le contenu en
carbone de chaque produit sous-produit
et cetera même même avoir pour un
produit qui est même fabriqué en
France se mettre d'accord sur
l'emprainte carbone du début jusqu'à la
fin du produit qui est fabriqué en
France c'est très compliqué alors
calculer calculer ça sur des produits en
Chine ça va être on veut faire une taxe
carbone honn si j'ose dire et vraiment
fonder sur le carbone c'est très
difficile moi j'avais suggéré en son
temps de faire une TVA kilométrique
c'est-à-dire de dire un produit qui sort
de Chine et qui fait X milliers de
kilomètr pour venir être vendu en France
il devrait payer une partie de TVA plus
importante qu'un produit qui est fait à
côté ça c'est peut-être plus facile à
mettre en uvre mais on voit bien que
l'Union européenne cherche depuis un
moment le moyen de faire payer la
protection sociale par les produits qui
sont ortés sur faire attention il faut
faire attention quand même il faut faire
attention à quelque chose quand même il
faut savoir qu'à peu près 60 % de la
consommation de bien courant en France
est importé donc si vous si vous
installez système de taxe à l'entrée une
forme d'impôt douigners et cetera le
principal effet c'est une augmentation
des prix sur 60 % du panier de
consommation des Français ouis donc ça
se traduit immédiatement par plus
d'inflation et donc ça va se traduire
immédiatement par des arbitrages vers le
locost dont on parlait toutande alors et
la la relance alors non je je continue
il faut savoir que depuis 50 ans vous
parliez de l'Allemagne tout à l'heure il
y a une différence fondamentale entre
les politiques macro-économiques de la
France France et les politiques
macro-économiques de l'Allemagne en
Allemagne c'est défense et promotion du
système productif allemand parce qu'on
croit que la spécialisation industrielle
est le cœur du modèle économique
allemand et donc du coup ça permet de
développer les exportations ça permet
mais du coup il n'y a pas l'importance
qui est mise sur le soutien de la
consommation à l'inverse en France vous
regardez depuis 50 ou 60 ans on ne parle
que de plan de relance de la
consommation h c'estàdire chaque fois
qu'il y a un accident conjoncturel quel
qu'il soit la réponse c'est depuis
giscardestin depuis 62 on soutient la il
y a quand même des plans de relance qui
sont dans l'investissement ça c'est sur
la table c'est pas
suffisant consmation c'est la
consommation évidment on a tous en tête
le plan le giga plan à plusieurs
centaines de milliards de de Joe Biden
l'Europe elle est à la hauteur justement
pour soutenir les investissements de de
demain sur l'industrie pas
tout d'ailleurs fa d'une quiie N pasér
qui n pas éé sur logique là il faut une
Europe qui sache protéger ses frontières
c'est imposer au produits importés les
mêmes règles que nous et une Europe qui
sache investir dans le développement
européen c'est ce qu'on évoqué tout à
l'heure d'une vraie industrie
stratégique européenne on en est loin il
y a encore beaucoup de chemins à faire
on va s'arrêter là en tout cas c'était
très clair et passionnant merci d'être
venu débattre sur le plateau d'lcp vous
restez avec moi Jérémy André dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties prix de
nos affranchis ce soir comment faire
baisser les prix justement des produits
décarbonés c'est la question que va se
poser la Falco dans Action planè marche
c'est évidemment le mot de la semaine de
Mariette d'arégrand et puis qui ira qui
n'ira pas à cette marche vous nous
racontez tout n'est-ce pas sur cette
marche contre l'antisémitisme dans
Bourbon Express stphanie ce soir oui je
vous raconte aussi comment
l'organisation de cette marche donne des
mots de tête à tout le paysage politique
et même à ces deux instigateurs il
Albron Pivet et Gérard Larcher à tout à
l'heure les amis mais d'abord on va
plonger dans l'horreur du 7 octobre avec
vous Jérémie André et avec les envoyés
spéciau du point en Israël un numéro
exceptionnel qui reconstitue heure par
heure le déroulé de cette journée de
massacre perpétré par le ramasse un
travail important un travail nécessaire
pour mesurer à quel point ce porome au
21e siècle a été coordonné regardez
c'est dans l'invitation d'amondingava on
en parle juste après
si on vous invite Jérémy André c'est
pour ce dossier majeur publié dans votre
journal Le Point 7 octobre 2023 un
poromme du 21e siècle la bordure
occidentale du kibut de faraza ce kibut
Jérémy André vous avez été sur les lieux
des massacres on est dans une petite
maison qui sert visiblement d'abri et où
on peut voir
au sol des traces de sang devant les
maisons des tirs donc VO des impacts de
ballle un peu partout dans celui-ci
c'est particulièrement atroce je pense
que là vous vous voyez bien avec des
coussins qui sont couvert de sang cette
semaine dans votre hebdomadaire on
retrouve un récit presque minute par
minute des attaques du Hamas du 7
octobre à 6h30 la clôture de sécurité é
réputé infranchissable est ouverte à 29
endroits les terroristes des brigades
alkassam la branche militaire du Hamas
rentrre sur le territoire
israélien le Dôme de fer le système
antimissile censé protégé Israël et
saturé des milliers de roquettes sont
tirées à 5 km de la bande de Gaza les
terroristes du Hamas fon sur le festival
supernova plus de 3000 féards tentent de
s'enfuir
près de 300 tombent sous les rafales de
kalashnikov les terroristes tu il
kidnappent aussi plus de 200 personnes
amené de force à Gaza les terroristes du
Hamas prennent d'assaut plusieurs kibuts
ses communautés agricoles il massacre
des femmes des enfants des
vieillards au bout de quelques heures
d'une attente min l'armée libère les
kibuts et découvre
l'horreur Jérémy André vous documentez
le plus grand massacre de juifs depuis
la Seconde Guerre mondiale et pourtant
vous le dites certains minimis ou
relativise alors pour convaincre faut-il
tout montrer tout
raconter réponse j'aV André je pense pas
qu'il faait tout montrer il faut
raconter le maximum et il faut bien
choisir ses mots et les détails qu'on
raconte faut les vérifier très
précisément donc c'est le travail qu'on
a fait c'est un travail
d'équipe voilà avec une dizaine de
journalistes cinq sur place et en
essayant de collecter au maximum des
témoignages directs vérifier recroiser
pour vraiment en fait comprendre la
mécanique dans cette journée qui a amené
donc voilà plus de 1400 morts du côté
israélien alors on va rembobiner le 7
octobre c'est un vendredi jour de
shabbat fête religieuse en Israël et
pourtant tout le monde n'a pas baissé la
garde on l' prend en vous lisant dans la
nuit à 3h du matin le directeur général
du chinbê les services de renseignement
intérieur israéliens remarquent une
agitation inhabituelle dans la bande de
Gaza et là alors une tentative il y
avait eu des d'envoyer mais non il y
avait eu des alertes pas seulement
celle-ci à la dernière minute mais en
fait plusieurs semaines auparavant entre
autres par exemple de jeunes femmes qui
observaient la frontière qui sont des
conscrites qui qu'on appelle les yeux de
salle le long de la bordure de sécurité
donc plusieurs semaines avant et on ne
le sait pas encore il y aura une enquête
d'ailleurs l'armée l'a assuré à la
presse internationale il y aura une
enquête interne pour savoir les raisons
de ces défa
le jour même à 3h du matin effectivement
les renseignements israéliens euh ont
euh des doutes quelques quelques heures
avant eu des euh informations précises
sur le brandbas de combat euh du côté
donc du Hamas euh ils nous ont envoyé
des unités sur place mais c'était
beaucoup trop tard beaucoup trop peu il
aurait fallu renforcer la défense de
l'ensemble de cette frontière alors on
va voir sur la carte à la fois par le
nord et par le sud de la bande de Gaza
la barrière de sécurité il faut bien
montrer c'est 6 m de haut 65 km de
longueur elle est franchie 29 points
sont sont franchi c'est énorme et il y a
eu des reconnaissances au petit matin
point de passage par des militants du
Hamas déguisés en agriculteur ouais
alors c'était le cas encore une fois
depuis des semaines hein ces ces yeux de
salle euh qui ont été d'ailleurs
massacrés
on avait
interviewé une une tente d'une de ces
conscrites et en fait sa mort a été
annoncée ce matin euh donc ses yeux de
salle avaient averti leur hiérarchie et
en vain euh ce matin-là encore une fois
elles ont vu l'attaque arriver mais en
fait euh donc plusieurs personnes parmi
ceux qu'on a intervieoué ont parlit de
l' imaginau cette barrière de sécurité
était en réalité inadaptée à ce type
d'attaque et même donc certains
militaires disent aujourd'hui que la
défense autour de Gaza avait été
négligée au profit en fait
de de s Jordanie et l'occupation aussi
la diversion par cette pluie de de
roquettes et puis ces drones qui
larguent des grenades pour neutraliser
les caméras et les et les canons
automatiques sur la barrière de de
sécurité il y a même des plongeurs qui
passe par la mer pour attaquer certains
certains kibos et là avec des engins les
les commandos du Hamas entre et et
quelles armes précisément ont-ils alors
finalement ils ont un arsenal très
abondant euh mais qui est absolument pas
surprenant donc un arsenal de euh groupe
armé euh donc de kalashnikov parfois
véust de mitrailleuses donc pk de
fabrication soviétique ou des imitations
et euh donc de euh de tuyaux d'arrosage
aussi j'ai vu capable de fracturer les
portes blindées effectivement
d'explosifs préparé minus minutieusement
préparé et euh donc de lance-roquet donc
euh ce qui est spécifique c'est d'avoir
tourné ces armes non pas d'abord sur des
bases militaires euh voilà il quatre
cinq bases militaires qui ont été
attaquées mais en fait c'est surtout il
y a une vingtaine de localités civiles
qui ont été visé euh par ses armes et
donc
voilàation d'armes lourdes sur des
personnes civiles désarmé estce qui
sidère aussi ce sont ces caméras ces
mini caméras les fameuses GoPro que que
ces terroristes ont décidé d'emmener
pour filmer leurs
atrocités alors je je je suis pas
certain que le but initial était de
filmer en fait la partie atrocité ou
c'est-à-dire que en fait depuis une
dizaine d'années les groupes armés les
groupes terroristes comme l'état
islamique filment de plus en plus
embarquent des euh donc service de
médias de ces groupes terroristes voilà
qui filment leurs actions et normalement
en fait ces vidéos auraient dû être
monté et diffusé je pense à la gloire
donc du Hamas et des autres groupes
armés palestinien en en coupant en fait
les parties horribles ce qu'ils font
toujours ou peut-être en retenant
uniquement C qui envoie un message de
choc d'effroid à l'égard de la société
israélienne là la différence c'est que
la plupart de ces terroristes ont été
tués au combat et donc l'armée
israélienne a récupéré énormément de ces
images et on a diffusé le contenu dont
des contenus qui sont effectivement
abominables où il tuent des civils 6h29
la rêve partie supernova qui bat son
plein dans le Négev c'est l'un des
massacres les plus insouten able
281 morts et vous racontez la jeune
mette Benaim qui comprend qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'une fusillade du Hamas mais
d'une battue une battue dont les
festivaliés sont le gibier et qui va
durer des heures alors c'est cette jeune
femme c'est qu d'assez incroyable c'est
la capitaine de soirée donc elle est
avec ses amis c'est celle qui a on va
dire le moins consommé de produits parce
qu'il faut être très clair en fait c'est
une rêve partie les gens prennent de la
MDMA ou d'autres donc drogue
allucinogène et elle elle est plutôt
voilà nette et en fait elle va emmener
ses amis donc c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
utilisé comme fil rouge elle a sauvé ses
ses amis en trouvant une cache
euh son témoignage ainsi que celui de la
dizaine de personnes qu'on a intervieoué
sur ce festival sont très importants
parce que ils montrent un acharnement
sur les corps une une volonté de tuer
sur des gens qui sont complètement
désarmés euh et aussi et alors là c'est
un énorme problème je pense dans ce que
nous on a trouvé et ce qui émerge de
certaines images c'est la participation
de civils palestiniens des gens qui ne
sont pas en tenue de combat et qui se
sont joints parfois dans une deuxième
vague à ces massacres et ça ça pose
vraiment des questions central sur
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ce jour-là par
par par sympathie pour ce qui se passait
par alors il possible qu' bre de ces
gens soit des combattants qui en fait
n'ont pas eu le temps de se préparer et
se sont
joint donc au mass il y a pas que ça he
parce qu'on va parler aussi des héros
des des Arabes israéliens qui ont qui
ont sauvé des Ju je voudrais qu'on dise
un mot sur omomer landler 27 ans rescapé
du du festival qui se souvient du
sourire sur le visage d'un terroriste
poignardant une jeune fille dans la
poitrine les corps perforés par les
couteaux de cuisine des morceaux de
cerveau éparpillés des corps tellement
carb bisé qu'il ressemble à un squelette
il vous dit l'air sentait le faire
tellement il y avait de sang h alors je
je pense que son témoignage il est
essentiel parce que en fait c'est
quelqu'un qui qui a aussi traversé en
fait tout tout ce massacre qui allit
dans plusieurs endroits qui a vu en fait
quelque chose qui a peu été documenté
c'est-à-dire le le final vraiment
barbare en fait de ce massacre pour pour
qu'il a 280 personnes qui était tué donc
si on compare par exemple à ce qui
s'était passé au Kenya en 2015 avec des
étudiants o il y avait eu 150 morts euh
ce qui c'était passé à bomb donc en 2008
c'est on est probablement dans une rien
que sur ce festival sur une des tueries
masses les plus importantes de
l'histoire récente avec et là on le voit
grâce au témoignag des survivants des
kibuts euh des communications
permanentes et ça c'est incroyable parce
que les groupes WhatsApp fonctionne tout
le monde se
prévient parfois on s'appelle parfois
même les terroristes ça c'est le cas
pour la rêve parti appelle les parents
des des otages qui vont être emmenés
vers Gaza en leur disant tout simplement
vous ne reverrez jamais vos fils ou vos
filles h bah c'est c'est c'est un
massacre virtuel aussi qui se qui où
tout le monde communique enfin c'est un
massacre réel mais où tout le monde
communique en même temps ouais alors
c'est vraiment on est arrivé dans une
ère où euh il y a l'Internet est
omniprésent et les applications sont
omniprésentes WhatsApp effectivement
dans de tous les côtés a eu un rôle
majeur
euh on a en fait effectivement ces
groupes WhatsApp où les gens en live
comprennent des éléments sur la
situation donc on a par exemple ce cas
dont on parle c'est la famille de Keren
et avidor Schwarzman qui sont le kibot
faraza et en fait ils perdent le contact
vers 17h avec les grands-parents euh
donc qui vivent quelques maisons plus
loin et en fait sur le moment le père
donc avidor comprend en fait ce qui se
passe mais il le dit pas à sa femme
parce que c'est ce sont donc ses beaux
parents ce sont les parents de sa femme
et euh voilà en fait il il y a quelque
chose de beaucoup plus instantané
aujourd'hui à cause ou grâce à ces
applications vous racontez aussi y ai
l'ando l'ambulancier qu'on va voir à
l'écran qui font en larme quand il
évoque le corps d'une femme enceinte
éventrée lors de la conférence de presse
un éventré dont on a arraché le fétus on
le voit puis je voudrais que vous dis
vous disiez un mot aussi sur sur les
résistants sur les héros Rami vidane qui
sauve des dizaines de jeunes et Youssef
zadney le Bédoin arabe israélien qui a
secouru les festivaliers racontez-nous
alors euh c'est c'est quelque chose qui
était peut-être passé inaperçu dans le
weekend d'or
donc du 7 octobre il y a eu des actes de
bravoure exceptionnels donc d'une part
il y a eu des kibboots qui ont réussi à
tenir en respect les assaillants donc on
en on parle de d'un de C k boost donc
mesfalsim voilà où une dizaine de
personnes armées ont réussi à tenir en
respect les les dizaines peut-être les
centaines de de personnes qui tentaient
d'investir le kibbots et puis aussi oui
et donc aussi donc en fait ces
sauveteurs donc comme Youssef comme Ramy
davidan dont je parle aussi dans
l'article comme Léon bar qui a sauvé met
ben Rahim et qui est mort pendant un
sauvetage
après donc et c'est ce que me disait met
c'est en fait on insiste sur le bilan
mais en fait s'il y avait pas eu cette
solidarité profonde dans la société
israélienne le bilan aurait été beaucoup
plus lourd merci beaucoup merci Jérémy
André et à toutes les équipes du point
les envoyés spéciaux en Israël et les
équipes de journalistes à Paris je
voudrais qu'on termine par cette image
le mémorial d'Aret que vous reprenez sur
deux pages à la fin de ce très long
papier c'est aujourd'hui les
1128 noms de victimes on le voit ici
s'afficher au officiellement identifié
c'est important aussi de tous les nommer
merci beaucoup Jérémy André c'est donc à
lire dans Le Point un pe grome 21e
siècle sur 30 pages à ne à ne pas
manquer parce qu'il faut la regarder en
face cette réalité c'est l'heure de
retrouver nos affranchis pour leur
partie prix vous pourrez réagir on les
accueille tout de suite Léa Falco pour
sa chronique écolo du vendredi Mariette
d' d'gance son mot de la semaine allez
on respire et on s'installe on va
commencer
par Stéphanie des pierres Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
c'est cette marche qui suscite la
polémique mais qui aura bien lieu ce
dimanche oui une polémique qui ne
faiblit pas faut-il marcher au côté de
la quarantaine de députés Ren dimanche
entre l'Assemblée et le Sénat ça dérange
la gauche ça dérange aussi une partie du
camp présidentiel alors toute la semaine
les deux initiateurs il y a elbron Pivet
et Gérard Larcher ont tenté d'éteindre
l'incendie et plaider pour une unité
national introuvable à l'heure qu'il est
les deux présidents martellent que c'est
une marche civique pour un sursut
républicain que les partis politiques ne
sont pas invité en tant que tel que le
rappel s'adresse aux Français que ce
n'est pas un meeting et qu'il n'y aura
qu'une seule banderole pour la
République contre l'antisémitisme comme
ils l'ont expliqué mercredi soir sur le
plateau du 20h et hier soir ils ont à
nouveau publié un communiqué pour
enfoncer le clou les polémiques inutiles
doivent cesser écrivent--il marcher
dimanche est une démarche individuelle à
part partisane et citoyenne alors
finalement quels sont les les partis qui
iront et ceux qui n'iront pas marcher
contre l'antisémitisme alors d'abord il
elbron Pivet voudrait que les chefs de
parti soient à l'arrière du cortège et
pas en tête écologiste et communistes et
socialistes ont finalement décidé d'y
participer ils l'ont dit dans un
communiqué commun mais ils appellent à
créer un cordon républicain à ne pas se
mêlé aux élus d'extrême droite alors en
pratique ça risque de ne pas être simple
le seul groupe qui boycotte c'est la
France insoumise Jean-Luc Mélenchon
fustige à la fois la participation du RN
et le soutien inconditionnel de yelbron
Pivet comme il l'écrit à Israël
plusieurs députés insoumis ont donc
préféré participer hier soir à des
hommages aux victimes de la Nuit de
Cristal perpétré par les nazis en 1938
et puis d'autres insoumis manifesteront
dimanche mais pas à Paris pour éviter
justement de se retrouver avec des
députés du rassemblement national
François Ruffin lui a choisi Strasbourg
ville de naissance d'un de ses héros il
explique que là-bas un appel clair des
organisateurs non le rassemblement
national l'extrême droite ne sont pas
les bienvenus c'est en effet la Licra
qui organise le rassemblement et qui l'a
dit le RN n'est pas invité elle y aura
aussi avec François Ruffin Alexis
corbierre et Raquel Garrido deux autres
contestataires vous le savez de la ligne
Mélenchon voilà et du côté du
gouvernement alors quels seront les les
ministres présents alors ellisabeth
borne sera en tête de corortège avec yel
Bron Pivet et Gérard Larcher la présence
du rassemblement national a aussi fait
débat au sein du gouvernement mais
mercredi le porte-parole Olivier verrand
disait que le RN n'avait pas sa place il
défilera lui mais dans son fief à
Grenoble Olivier dusopte lui par exemple
marchera à Paris au moins 25 ministres
seront dans le défilé parisien tout
comme les anciens présidents Nicolas
Sarkozi et François Hollande mais pour
l'instant on ne sait pas si Emmanuel
Macron sera présent merci beaucoup
Stéphanie piierre d'OT Jérémy André vous
pensez que sa présence serait serait
utile il faut qu'il y aille le président
de la République un message d'unité
nationale à apportter il y a quand même
neuf de nos ressortissants qui sont
entre les mains de des groupes
terroristes des groupes armés qui ont
commis ces ces crimes il y a
40 ressortissants français qui ont été
tués et la communauté juive de France
est assez naturellement très inquiète
alors euh euh voilà je pense que dès le
début c'était pas le moment de
manifester pour les Palestiniens
bombardés même si c'est terrible ce qui
leur arrive aujourd'hui avoir un débat
sur est-ce qu'il faut manifester contre
l'antisémitisme alors que vient de se
produire l'acte antisémite
violent des 70 dernières années ça me
semble absurde voilà je je précise que
la Chaîne Parlementaire va retransmettre
en direct une émission spéciale à la
fois dans le dans le cortège avec de de
nombreux invités en plateau ce sera à
suivre à partir de 14h30 sur LCP Léa on
a parlé vêtement dans notre premier
débat sur la face fashion notamment vous
vous nous parlez habillement mais quoi
seconde main plutôt c'est ça vêtement de
seconde main c'est ça dont on parle
aujourd'hui parce que vous l'avez
peut-être entendu ces derniers jours le
gouvernement a mis en place une
subvention pour faire repriser vos
vêtements concrètement ça veut dire que
vous pouvez amener vos t-shirts troué ou
vos chaussures avec une petite accroche
chez un réparateur agréé et que vous
avez une réduction sur le prix qui va
être financé par une écotaxe de quelques
centimes sur les produits neufs donc
étant donné qu'un Français moyen
consomme à peu près 9 kg et demi de
vêtements neuf par an c'est plutôt une
mesure qui va dans le bon sens ou qui en
tout cas envoie un bon signal même si
évidemment elle est complexe et qui a le
risque et fasse monter les prix
initiauux des réparateurs mais derrière
cette mesure là il y a aussi des
questions plus complexes et donc des
réponses à trouver pourquoi est-ce que
on achète autant de vêtements pourquoi
est-ce qu'on ne répare pas d'ors et déjà
les vêtements qu'on a et qui sont abîmés
alors déjà P Mael on peut un petit peu
citer le fait que ce soit socialement
valorisé aujourd'hui d'avoir beaucoup de
vêtements compris si on les porte pas le
fait qu'on ait parfois du mal a trouvver
le temps après une journée entière de
travail de transport à aller faire
réparer des chaussettes plutôt que d'en
acheter d'autres le fait que évidemment
on ne sait pas toujours le faire que de
plus la qualité des vêtements s'est
progressivement dégradée puisque c'est
plus intéressant pour les industriels
d'en faire acheter d'autres que de les
faire durer dans le temps tout ça ça
fait tout un tas de raisons qui font que
c'est une mesure qui pourrait aller dans
le bon sens mais qui n'est pas
suffisante toutes ces raisons ce sont
autant d'excuses à vos yeux ou pas bah
sinon excuse au moins on peut s'accorder
sur le fait qu'aujourd'hui on vit tous
sous contrainte que ce soit des
contraintes économiques finan des
contraintes d'espace et à côté on a
pourtant la l'injonction à la
consommation en permanence et cette
contradiction fait que la plupart du
temps et de manière tout à fait
naturelle on va se tourner vers la
solution qui est la plus simple pour
nous et le choix le plus simple le choix
qui est donc le plus économique le plus
rapide le plus socialement valorisé qui
nous fait perdre le moins de temps et
ben c'est très rarement le choix écolo
au contraire celui-là il demande
beaucoup d'abnégation pour y aller
reprenons l'exemple des vêtements si
j'ai un trou dans mon jean et que ça me
coûte moins cher d'en racheter un autre
et qu'en plus ça me fait perdre du temps
pour aller au répar j'ai pas forcément
envie de perdre ce temps-là le système
qu'il faut construire c'est un système
dans lequel ça coûte plus cher d'aller
acheter un nouveau Jean que de faire
réparer celui qu'on a déjà donc en plus
on parle même pas seulement de de coût
économique hein mais de temps de
respectabilité sociale enfin voilà cette
mesure là de subvention de réparation
elle peut contribuer à la création d'un
nouveau système vestimentaire presque on
pourrait appeler à la condition de se
souvenir qu'elle n'est pas suffisante et
que de fait il va falloir des
modifications plus structurelles et qui
dépassent les les individus pour réussir
à faire en sorte que le choix par défaut
ce soit un choix écolo merci merci
beaucoup on avance on chemine doucement
peut-être un peu trop lentementesè
sûrement merci allez on enchaîne avec le
mot marche c'est votre mot forcément de
la semaine Maria d'égrand oui un mot
inévitable cette semaine qui est un mot
très simple he tout le monde sait ce que
ça veut dire je dirais même que c'est un
mot instinctif si on prend le test de la
marche qu'on fait passer au petit bébé
qui vient de naître c'est très amusant
parce qu'il a ses petites
jambes qui ne feront pas encore le geste
tout de suite ça va être un an ou un an
et demi après mais il faut voir si le
petit Tomo arrivant au monde est capable
de faire ce qu'a fait l'homo ctus l'homo
sapiens c'est-à-dire se mettre sur ses
pattes arrières et commencer à activer
son cerveau c'est comme ça qui s'est
passé et tous les grands penseurs ont
raconté quelque chose autour de ça hein
de Socrate à à Nietzsche en passant par
Rousseau faire agir en même temps notre
tête et nos jambes c'est quelque chose
de remarquable que les neuroscien
aujourd'hui ben vente et donc c'est
devenu très tendance de marcher dans la
rue dans la ville ou dans la nature et
ça sera aussi ça cette démarche de la
marche dimanche alors ça va pas être
sportif mais ça va être plutôt puisqu'il
y a l'idée que ça va être une marche
civique je trouvais ça intéressant ce
cette alliance parce que évidemment ça
nous fait penser aux années Martin
Luther King qui ne les Américains n'ont
pas dit walk ils n'ont pas marcher
tranquillement c'était pas la petite
balade c'était la ils ont repris le mot
européen le mot latin si on veut de de
la marche la longue marche des droits
civies et là bien on a la dimension
combattive de la marche alors chez nous
aussi c'est arrivé en
politique sur un degré disons mineur
mais qui a été très efficace
quandah en 2017 Emmanuel Macron bah oui
bien sûr son mouvement qui s'appelait en
marche et s partisens les marcheurs
voilà donc il a repris d'ailleurs ce que
Nicolas Sarkozi avait fait un peu le
contre l'immobilisme à la française mais
le fait de d'avoir pris le concept de
marche a été très très efficace alors
c'est très bien pour partir des concepts
comme ça de cette métaphore c'est
beaucoup moins bien pour continuer pour
filer la métaphore hein donc je vais
prendre un petit exemple que j'aime
beaucoup en ce moment euh c'est qu vous
savez l'expression ça marche h vous
commandiez un café il y a quelques
années Myriam dans un mistro et on vous
disait oui bien sûr et cetera maintenant
le jeune serveur ou la jeune serveuse va
vous dire ok ça marche et puis souvent
il revient 2 minutes après c'était quoi
déjà que vous vouliez qu'elle était la
commande je prends cet exemple parce que
pour dire que de certains un jeune
diplômé dans notre pays n'ont pas trouvé
l'emploi qui correspond à leur diplôme
et du coup bah ça pour moi ça fait
partie justement de la longue marche du
politique c'est long ça va prendre des
années et bon Len nous l'explique
souvent ça commence par des petites
choses mari en quelques mots pour
conclure le temps de nous écouter ça va
marcher dimanche et ben je l'espère
fortement j'espère que la France va se
rappeler qu'elle a su réhabiliter
l'honneur du capitaine drefus mais je
crois qu'elle doit aussi regarder cette
marche comme peut-être le premier pas
vers son avenir mais là ça sera pas pour
dimanche ce sera pour lundi parce que on
marche toujours vers quelque chose donc
vers quoi marcher dimanche est-ce que
c'est la nouvelle démocratie contre la
la théocratie est-ce que c'est le
l'humanisme à l'européenne qu'il faut
réhabil enfin reprendre réinventer quel
va être le but des gens qui vont marcher
dimanche dans Paris en plus évidemment
du socle fondamental de s'inscrire
contre l'antisémitisme merci beaucoup en
tout cas rendez-vous 14h30 sur LCP pour
suivre EN DIRECT cette marche ce sera la
marche parisienne de l'Assemblée
nationale au Sénat merci beaucoup Jérémy
André Le le 7 octobre 2023 minute par
minute c'est-à-dire dans les dans les
colonnes du point cette semaine avec
tout le le service des envoyés spéciaux
mais aussi des des journalistes à Paris
pour pour le point merci les affranchis
à très vite Stéphanie des pierres c'est
le weekend merci à tous ceux qui
derrière ma la caméra m'accompagne
fidèlement très très bon weekend et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]